on va voir on l'a vu quelques secondes
avant la courbe c'est quand même parce
qu'on parle pas de ça tous les jours on
est parti 2015-2016 on avait 63 63
personnes qui ont choisi de mourir comme
ça en ayant une date parce qu'il n'en
pouvait plus et ça monte ça monte à nez
après année et 2022 2023 on croit qu'on
va dépasser le 5000 personnes je lisais
c'est à peu près 5% des décès au Québec
madame Yvon est-ce que vous est-ce que
c'était quelque chose que vous aviez
imaginé que ça augmente comme ça autant
est-ce que c'est normal ce que ça vous
inquiète ou vous en êtes là
je pense que en fait ça démontre la
force de l'approche québécoise tout
simplement dans le sens où on a
travaillé autour de ces questions-là
très sensibles dans la collaboration en
impliquant la population les experts
donc quand c'est arrivé c'était
travailler depuis des années et donc le
consensus était établi il y avait un
niveau de confort et de sécurité pour
répondre à cet enjeu-là qu'il faut pas
oublier qu'on est une des populations
les plus vieillissantes au monde donc
c'est pas quelque chose non plus à
négliger quand on voit ces chiffres là
dans la mesure où c'est très bien
encadré la Commission des soins de fin
de vie dit que tout est réglé au corps
de Tours et que tous les critères sont
bien respectés je pense pas qu'on
devrait s'en inquiéter parce que docteur
vient vous allez nous confirmer que
c'est fait de façon très méticuleuse
c'est rien n'est fait c'est une évidence
vous allez me dire mais la légère
depuis 7 ans et la commission suivie
elle-même reconnaît que
probablement 99% et des poussières de
ces colonnes sont des cas tout à fait
conformes à la Loi
l'augmentation on constate un fait c'est
quasiment une courbe linéaire
augmentation que je trouve absolument
normal et je m'en réjouis beaucoup ça
veut simplement dire que l'aide à mourir
répondait à un besoin que ce besoin là
n'est pas encore complètement comblé et
ça se fait il offre de service et de
plus en plus adapté à cette demande-là
et moi c'est je vois pour aucun effort
quand je vois que les gens nous
comparent au Benelux
à la Belgique
c'est très très relié d'abord une
situation personnelle de grande
souffrance dans un moment
critique approchant de leur fin de vie
si tous les c'est tout s'est passé en
zone ne demande pas les la mourir ben
c'est que
des circonstances socioculturelles qui
font que pour certaines personnes c'est
pas une méthode acceptable par contre
pour d'autres et
même
parmi des patients qui ont été en
contact qui ont reçu de très bons soins
palliatifs il y en a une proportion
là-dedans pour lesquelles les soins
palliatifs les meilleurs ne peuvent pas
apporter une réponse satisfaisante alors
souffrance existentielle de finition il
va toujours y avoir un besoin pour
l'aide à mourir quel que soit la qualité
des soins palliatifs et la qualité des
soins palliatifs c'est améliorée depuis
le début c'est la crainte c'était la
crainte théorique Véronique ils vont de
dire puisqu'on a maintenant l'aide
médicale à mourir est-ce que ça va
affaiblir ou est-ce que on va éviter de
donner de meilleurs soins palliatifs
pour empêcher les gens de souffrir à la
fin de vie vous êtes bon docteur vient
vous pensez que non vernis qui vont
c'était une des craintes aussi au départ
là
oui c'est un grand crainte puis je pense
la force encore une fois je veux pas
être chauffée mais ce qu'on a fait au
Québec c'est qu'on est les seuls au
monde d'avoir une loi qui intègre le
droit aux soins palliatifs et sur un
continuum jusqu'à la médicale à mourir
c'est les souffrances ne sont pas
soulagées et que c'est ce que la
personne désire donc c'est très fort
parce que c'est pas une approche qui est
sur l'aide médicale à mourir de manière
isolée de manière complètement abstraite
déconnecter de la réalité de la maladie
et des soins qu'on veut prodiguer à
quelqu'un alors ça ça fait une force et
oui il y a toujours du travail à faire
mais je peux vous dire qu'on avait
investi en soins palliatif et je pense
que les choses s'améliorent beaucoup et
d'ailleurs la grande majorité des gens
qui reçoivent la nuit jusqu'à la mourir
ont eu des soins palliatifs c'est la
commission de contrôle qui nous dit
c'est pas un ou l'autre bon je vais je
vais vous montrer un tableau maintenant
on propose d'élargir et alors ça reste
pour les maladies graves et incurables
bien sûr
handicap neuromoteur quelqu'un qui est
quadraplégique par exemple donc on
retire l'obligation d'être en fin de vie
le retrait du critère de fin de vie on
l'enlève et c'est une grosse un gros
changement potentiel on permet les
demandes anticipées si moi j'en dis pas
voir l'Alzheimer dans 20 ans je peux
signer un papier puis dire si je suis
dans tel et tel état donnez-moi l'aide
médicale à mourir même si je ne serai
plus apte compte tenu de mon Alzheimer à
jugé ça c'est quand même vers un
équivaut un gros changement là qu'on
ajoute
oui c'est un très gros changement puis
encore une fois on est précurseur on
trace une nouvelle voie pour répondre à
beaucoup beaucoup de besoins je dirais
de difficultés de souffrance qui nous
ont été soumises c'est extrêmement
complexe mais encore une fois c'est une
réponse qui se veut empreinte je dirais
à la fois de grandes prudence d'humanité
de respect de la personne et quand on a
fait le débat de manière très sérieuse
en commission transpartisane on a
atteint un niveau de sérénité par
rapport à cette question là pour dire on
pense être capable de l'encadrer d'une
manière telle que on va être capable de
donner cette possibilité là sans qu'il
puisse y avoir des enjeux éthiques et
que aussi on va avoir des citoyens qui
vont être prêts à le faire donc le
diable est dans les détails mais il y a
un moyen d'encadrer ça pour donner
réponse à ces gens-là qui sauvent vous
le vivez docteur vient vous en avez je
le répète j'en ai fait plus de 200 les
demandes d'anticiper est-ce que vous
êtes totalement à l'aise avec ça parce
que la personne que vous aurez devant
vous le jour x le jour J devrait-je
n'est pas la même personne que signé
c'est un cas avant là
je suis je suis entièrement favorable
pour l'introduction de cette nouvelle
modalité qui permettent les directives
anticipées dans les cases cependant j'ai
lu rapidement le nouveau projet de loi
en gros je pense que c'est c'est un
grand portrait mais comme le disait
madame Yvon Le diable est dans les
détails et j'aimerais beaucoup un
message que je parle c'est que j'espère
que le législateur voit compléter un peu
la consultation qui a été débuté à
l'automne 2021 et qu'on va s'intéresser
à avoir la vie des quelques mille
médecins qui sont les 1000 volontaires
qui sont à la source des plus de 7000
codes à mourir ça fait 7 ans
qu'on se bat pour adapter la loi le
mieux possible pour satisfaire les
besoins des patients
on a des choses à dire sur la nouvelle
loi et c'est pas en trois minutes ce
soir qu'on va régler ça
il faut qu'on puisse avoir l'occasion
d'aller
représenter l'expérience qu'on a vu la
réflexion qu'on a vu d'accord mais vous
dites il est possible
je vais vous forcer à répondre
rapidement maintenant vous êtes il est
possible de d'encadrer les demandes
d'anticiper de telle sorte que on ne
fausse pas
le moment présent d'une personne qui
aurait pu changer d'idée
c'est tout à fait
compatible la logique c'est une c'est
une excellente avancée parfaite mais ça
présente des difficultés qu'on n'a pas
encore vécu depuis 7 ans mais on a vécu
des situations qui nous font ressentir
que on doit faire attention maintenant
sur la façon dont on va construire très
bien la réalisation de cette nouvelle
initiative on y reviendra docteur vient
à plusieurs reprises on va suivre ça le
processus de consultation Véronique qui
vont en terminant on exclut les troubles
mentaux pas pour toujours nécessairement
mon exclu le fédéral et étudie ça par
ailleurs
oui c'était la recommandation aussi de
notre commission transpartisanale ce qui
montre que en fait quand on fait un
débat pour retourner toutes les pierres
d'ailleurs ils vont avoir un nouveau
débat qui va s'amorcer sur le handicap
neuromoteur j'imagine qu'on y reviendra
ce soir on manque peut-être le temps
mais en fait chaque débat doit être pris
dans son ensemble de manière très
sérieuse avec couverture je dirais mais
aussi en retournant chaque pierre et
avec beaucoup de prudence et c'est ce
qui nous a amené la Commission à dire
que le Québec n'était pas prêt pour
franchir le pas pour les maladies
psychiatriques parce qu'on ne sent pas
ce niveau de consensus là qui donne la
sérénité la légitimité ou législateur de
le faire et là le nouveau débat va être
sur le handicap neuromoteur pour voir où
se situe ce consensus sur ce tout autre
débat également
très bien merci beaucoup Véronique Yvon
docteur Pierre viens merci de nous avoir
parlé on va suivre ça c'est une question
importante et je pense que ça ça
éclairait les gens notre discussion
aussi brève soit elle merci beaucoup le
docteur vient Véronique qui vont à la
prochaine